字幕: Mizuho WATANABE
校正: Chie Kosuga
私は 今 紹介してくださったように
イグノーベル賞というのを
いただきましたけれども
今日はですね
今日は ちょっと違う話を
させていただきたいと思います
みなさんは今 こちらを見ています
私は反対に みなさんの方を
見ているわけです
今 私たちは同じ場所にいて
同じイベントに参加しているわけですけども
それぞれの目に映る光景っていうのは
全然違います
見る方向 つまり視点が違う
わけですから
当たり前ですよね
今日 私がお話ししたいことは
この当たり前のことなんです
この当たり前すぎることが 実は
とんでもなく奥深かったということ
これを
これまでの研究生活というんですかね
その経験から
お話ししたいというふうに思います
ことあるごとに 何度も何度も
アンダーラインを引き直してきた
そして 再確認してきた
見方を変えると 見え方が変わる
っていうことです
私は
だいたい30年ぐらい
25年ぐらいかな
単細胞生物の研究をしてきました
単細胞
といいましても 僕のことではありませんよ
（笑）
ネンキン といいます
お金の話ではありません
非常にねばねばした
巨大なアメーバ様生物というのがおります
これをずっと研究しながら
ご飯を食べてきたわけです
ですから 人呼んで 私は
ネンキン生活者 というふうに
（笑）
（拍手）
ありがとうございます
これでだいぶ リラックスできました
それで みなさん
粘菌って 聞いたことはありますか?
あります？
えーっ！
お金じゃないほうですよ ありますか？
すごいですね こんなに
意外なほど
２割ぐらいの方は 聞いたことがある
というわけです
こんな生き物です
黄色く見えてるものがあります
これがひとつ こんな大きいんですけども
一匹の巨大な
単細胞アメーバというわけです
見た感じは
ベタベタした マヨネーズみたいな姿形
ですからこの写真もですね どちらが粘菌で
どちらがマヨネーズか
全然区別がつかない
（笑）
当然 単細胞ですから
脳や神経っていうものは ありません
単細胞っていう言葉を
広辞苑で引きますと
考えの単純なこと
というふうに書いてあります
です はい
僕もそうなんですけど それで
でも考えてみますと 単細胞生物
この地球に現れたのは
もう何億年も前の話
私たち人間の
何百倍 何千倍も 長い間
ちゃんと 生き抜いてきてるわけです
そう考えると
我々のめっちゃ先輩なわけですね
ですよね？
だからそう考えると
少し見え方が変わってくるんじゃないか
っていうふうに思うわけです
普段は こんなふうにして飼っています
エサは オートミール
この白く見えてる粒々が ありますでしょ？
この一つ一つが
オーツ麦っていう麦の一種
それを乾燥させたものです
これを与えますと
そこへ 粘菌は集まってきて
養分を吸収して
大きくなって
あちこち こう
動いていくっていうふうにします
こういうのを 毎日１回世話しながら
何年も何年も 粘菌を飼い続けてきた
これが非常に健康な状態
こんなふうに
こんな形で
元気な姿を見せてくれる
今 こんな感じって 僕は言いました
あるときですね ふと
こんな感じって まぁ
どういう感じなのかなって
自問自答したんですね
よく見るとですね
粘菌の 体の中に
筋のようなものが見えますでしょ？
これ 血管のようになっていて
中を栄養とか情報が
行き来してるわけです
この管
なんとなくですね
あちこちに散らばったオートミールを
なんか つないでいるようにできてる
もしそうだとしたら
これはどういうふうに つないでるんだろうか
というふうに まず思った
それが粘菌にとって
どういう 生理的な意義ですね
彼らにとって 意味があるんだろうか
で もしエサ場所をうまくつなぐように
血管網を作るとしたら
これは粘菌にとってですね
どういうふうに つないだらいいのかっていう
ひとつの解くべき問題
その問題を どういうふうな
計算方式というか
解決方法で
答えを導き出してるんだろうか
などなどなどですね
次々に具体的な
問いとなってですね
言語化されたものが 頭の中にこう
立ち上がってきたんですね
ひとたび そういうふうになりますと
もうそういう考え抜きに
この粘菌の姿を見ることができなくなった
みなさんも先ほどから
この粘菌の姿を見てますけれども
最初と少し違って
見えるようになってきてませんか？
（笑）
きっと なってることと思います
ずっと僕はこういう
粘菌の研究をしてきましたけれども
こんな研究をしてきて 何が楽しいのか
というとですね
こういうふうに
見え方が どんどん どんどん変わってくる
新しい問題意識を出して
見え方が変わっていく
世界の見え方が際限なく変わっていく
これがやっぱり 一番面白かった
これが僕にとって
ひとつの大きい
見方を変えると 見え方が変わる
っていう瞬間でした
これはですね
一匹の粘菌が迷路の中に
閉じ込められている
赤いところに これからエサを置きます
赤いニコニコマークのところ
みなさんだったらどうしますか？
これ お腹が減ってて
エサが欲しい
粘菌は ４時間ぐらい経つと
こんな形に変わります
行き止まりのところに
伸びてた体を引き上げて
エサの上に移動して行って
養分を吸収する
さらに時間が経ちますと
これ ４つのですね 通路
エサ場所をつなぐ 接続経路すべてを
管を作って そこを示してるわけですね
さらに時間が経つと
このうちの１つだけを選んで
しかもそれが一番短い経路
それを取って
その他のところは エサの上に行って
養分を吸収するっていう形になる
とにもかくにも こんな簡単な実験から
粘菌には 迷路の最短経路を
単細胞ですよ
探し出す計算能力がある
っていうことが分かった
で まぁ なかなかやるだろう
やるんじゃない？
やるじゃん！
っていうふうに思ったわけです
まずですね このときに思ったのは
広辞苑を 書き換えなきゃいけない
っていうふうに思ったわけです
（笑）
これ どんなふうにして
じゃあ 問題を解いてるのか
最短経路を 探してるのか
っていうわけですけども
ええっと
これ自律分散方式の解き方っていうことが
分かりました
粘菌 こう 血管があります
これはですね
流れが活発だと太くなるし
流れがあまり活発でないと 細くなるっていう
性質があるってことが分かりました
それだけで 最短経路が
導かれてるということなんです
つまり 管の 血管の部分部分ですね
それが つながったものが
粘菌の総体
体のすべてっていうふうに
なってるわけですけども
その部分の管ですね
それは自分のところの流れだけに反応して
いわば身勝手に太さを変えている
にもかかわらず 全体として
いい解が出てくる
隣の管が どういう状態かってことは
一切関知しない
こういうのをですね
自律的に太さを変える管が
あちこちにあって
それで 答えを出すという意味で
自律分散方式というふうに 呼ばれています
これ シミュレーションの様子です
これを見つけたのが
まぁ 15年ぐらい前です
ずいぶん興奮してですね
わくわくしたのを覚えています
ところが残念ながらですね
業界の人は
ほとんど振り向いてくれなかった
そんな時期が ６年とか７年ぐらいあった
その間ですね
この業界にとどまるっていうんですか
生き残るために
それなりに苦労をした
そのときに
心のよりどころとして 思ってたことは
非常に素朴ですけれども
どこかにですね 学問の神様がいて
僕のことを見ていてくださる
もっと短的に言うと
お天道様が見ててくれる
だからまぁ もうちょっと がんばってやってみよう
というふうに思って やってきた
まぁ そういう無視 とは別にですね
ほとんど無視されてたっていう
状況とは別に
僕自身の粘菌に対する関心っていうのは
ますます深まっていった
これはですね
もうちょっと エサ場所が
たくさんあったときに
これ36個ありますけれども
そこを粘菌が うまくエサ場所をですね
つなぐっていう そういう
絵柄になっています
３つ特徴があったんですね
１つは
ちょっと理屈っぽい話ですけども
全体をなるべく短い距離で
つなぎましょうっていう 経済性
２番目はどこかが たまさか断線したときに
切れたときにですね
どこかに迂回路があって
全体のつながりが維持されるっていう
そういう ある種の故障に対する耐性
３番目はですね
エサ場所 ２つ取ってきたときに
その距離が なるべく短い距離で
つながっていた方が良かろうっていう 効率
この３つを うまく満たしてる
この３つはですね それぞれを
ベストな状態にして実現するっていうことが
不可能な問題なんですね
粘菌は それをうまく妥協させて
どれもそこそこ 実現しているような
ネットワークを作ってる
っていうことが分かった
これ なかなかすごい
もう お気づきかもしれませんけれども
この エサ場所の配置っていうのは
関東圏の 主だった街の分布
それに合わせて 置いてあるわけです
とすれば この粘菌の形と
実際の たとえば鉄道網のネットワーク
これを比較してみることができる
で 早速やってみた
そうすると 分かったんです
非常に 鉄道網が
よくできてるっていうことが
粘菌程度によくできている
（笑）
これで驚いたのは
単細胞のアメーバの研究を
してきたわけですけども
その向こうにですね
人間社会のやってること
そういうものが 少し透けて見えてきた
これから やっぱり
人間社会のやってることに対する見方が
少し変わってきたんですね
この研究をしているときに
このネットワークの形を
どんなふうに評価しようか
最初は アイデアがなかったわけですね
こういう粘菌の実験
粘菌が作ったネットワークの形の
写真というのを 撮りまして
大きく引き伸ばしました
その筋に合わせてですね
糸を こう置いていって その糸の長さを測る
こういう手作業を
何十枚何百枚の写真に対して
一枚一枚やってったわけです
そのころ 同業者はですね
そういう作業っていうのは
時間の無駄だって言うんですね
画像処理でやれば一発でわかる
こういう作業はですね
人間性を むしろ阻害する
人間のやることではない
というふうに 言われたんですね
でも 半分はそうかなって
思ったんですけども
少し それは違う
っていうふうに 思ってたんですね
ずーっと こう 一枚一枚の写真に
手でなぞりながら
粘菌の ネットワークの形を
追体験する
ということをやっていますと
まぁ こんな感じのつなぎ方だよね
っていうふうな感覚が こう
芽生えてきたっていうか そういうことが
思えるようになってきたわけですね
これって 無意識のところで
この形に対する理解が
何か進んでるっていう
証拠だと思うんですね
そういうものがあれば
そこからですね
何か言語化した見方 問題意識を
引き出すことが できるかもしれない
ひとたび そうなれば
それは もう
この問題に対して
見方を実際に変えてってくれる
糸口になるというわけです
ですから こういう本物の形に 触れる
どうしていいか分からないけれども
ずっと触れ続けてる
その時間というのは
とても大事なものだろう というふうに
思うわけです
そこを 画像処理で一発でやりますと
何もですね
無意識のところの理解が進まない
というふうに 危惧したりします
こんな粘菌の研究をしてくると
粘菌方式の解き方っていうのを
たとえば カーナビですね
えぇ カーナビに
使ってみたらどうだろうか
っていう可能性が
あったりするわけです
はじめはですね
単細胞の技術をですね
われわれのカーナビに使うなんてことは
思ってもみなかったわけですけれども
こういう可能性が 拓けてきたんですね
実際は あんまり拓けてないんですけども
（笑）
あの 売り込みに行ってるんですけども
なかなか あの はい
世の中 なかなか厳しいですけども
まあ そういうふうになってですね
でもですよ
いつか みなさんのカーナビを開けると
マヨネーズみたいなものが
ドロッと入ってるっていうことが
（笑）
来ないとも限らない
ぜひ来てほしいと思うんですけども
まぁ こんなことをやりながら
来たんですが
まぁ あの
いいときもあれば
そうでなかったときも あるわけですね
最初の６年７年は
ほとんど まぁ 無視されてたわけです
そういう頃にですね
僕は そもそも 何がしたいのか
何をやっていると幸せなのか
っていうことを
やっぱり自問自答するわけです
はじめは
よく分からなかったんですけれども
だんだんですね
分かる 意識できるようになってきた
自分の原点 研究の原点は何か
１つはですね
みなさま ご存知だと思いますけど
ファーブル昆虫記っていうのがあります
これが はっきり原点として
意識できるようになった
ファーブル昆虫記
２つ 感心することがあります
１つはですね
あの ごくありふれた
すぐ 近くにある
何の変哲もない空き地 荒れ地で
彼は 研究を成しえたっていうこと
もう１つは
観察 ですね
肉眼の観察と 簡単な実験で
みんなが驚くような
非常に明快な結論を
導き出してるっていうこと
これは だから 誰でも
やろうと思えば できた
ですよね？
でも ファーブルしかできなかった
それは そういう見方が
やっぱり必要だったわけです
ですから
ファーブルにとっては
何の変哲もない単なる
荒地っていうんですか
草地っていうのは
存在しなかっただろう
というふうに思うわけです
そこにはめくるめく 虫のですね 必死の生活
驚くべき生活が
もう 見えてたと 思うんですね
ファーブルしか見えなかった世界を
彼だけが見てた
っていうことなんだろうと思います
こういう 「見方」 ですね
どんなふうに まぁ
自分自身
探していったらいいんだろうか
っていうことが
もう１つの問題なんです
最後に そのことをお話ししたいと思います
原点という意味でいいますと
もう１つ別の側面があります
僕は 小学校のときに
一番好きだった教科が
図画工作なんですね
図画工作がある日は
もう前からですね ウキウキして
今日は 学校へ行きたい
っていうふうに 思ってたわけですね
図画工作
まぁ 最初 創意工夫します
その後 手作業ですね
手作業 ずっと地道に
うー 投げ出したいっていうことも
置いといてですね
積み重ねていく
最後に作品ができる
その作品は
見れば見るほど
自分の自己表現になっている
その作品を介して
言葉ではできなかったコミュニケーションが
他の人と取れるっていうことも分かった
そういうことはですね 今の研究
活動と 非常に重なるところが多い
だから 僕のやってることは
その頃 小学校の頃の図画工作の
真っすぐ延長線上にあります
創意工夫するときの 頭の使い方と
新しい見方を 何とか作り出そう
っていう 頭の使い方
これは まったく同じものです
作品ができたときに 心が満たされる
その満たされ方
それと 研究が論文としてまとまって
発表できたときの
心の満たされ方っていうのは
やっぱり まったく同じもの なんですね
こういうのを どんなふうにして
自分自身 探してきたか
と思うとですね
最後は
自分の感受性が頼り
知的感受性みたいなものが
頼りだったっていうふうに思います
小学校の頃もですね
机に座りながら
みんな なんか すごいなって思って
自分ひとりがですね
劣ってるなって
よく思ってたわけです
みんな こんなふうに 色んなことを
理解したり
発表したりできるけれども
僕は全然できないなっていう
まぁ そういうことを
非常によく考えた
そんなふうには 僕は感じないぞ
っていうようなことも
たくさんあったんですね
そういう自分をですね
だんだんだんだん
心の奥底に 仕舞っていって
あまり表に出すっていうことが
なかったんですけども
やっぱり どこかで そういう自分を
可愛がるといいますか
大事に思ってたわけですね
そういう自分が いつも
最後は 助けてくれた というわけです
ですから みなさんの心の中にも
そういう自分が いらっしゃると思います
いないわけないと 思うんですね
みなさんの人格っていうのは
固有なものですから
必ず固有の「見方」っていうのが
あると思います
そういう自分は ともすると
暴走したりですね
すぐ 心の中で 迷子になったり
してしまうんですけども
それを 努めて見失わないように
しっかり手を握って
抱きかかえてやってきた
というのが
これまでの研究生活だったのかなって
いうふうに思います
以上です
どうもご清聴ありがとうございました
（拍手）